[Musique]
c'est à mascara jardin botanique de la
réunion que s'est déroulée la journée de
l'éducation au développement durable
six collèges et lycées sont venus dressé
leurs stands afin de présenter leurs
actions
la piscine du stand fait des tournées en
emblème de mcdonald's pour dénoncer la
réalité de la malbouffe
ici on a des produits chimiques
il ya écrit une grille mills avait dit
recul après on est mangée makhzen et
encore on a encore fait
ici on la maquille hadès donc c'est pour
nous c'est que ma femme est vraiment de
mauvaises de mauvaise séquence est
mauvais au fait pour larguer en notre
stand résume tout ce qu'ils ont fait aux
pour eux cette année donc autour de la
solidarité qui est notre projet par mon
coeur
par exemple pour la récolte et de
nourriture c'est parfois des les gens
qui avaient acheté des concerts et qu'il
ne souhaitait pas consommer pour nous
allons aussi une récolte de jouer pour
la mutuelle passage et donc les anciens
jouets donnés un événement de verre
l'état ont été donnés mais qu'il est
effectivement une partie de recyclage
la première partie est composée de
plantes par de plantation on a ramené de
la terre avec des graines qui viennent
de chez nous qui sont endémiques de
notre collège
on a cassé dépendent a pris les fruits
et après quand on les ouvre on trouve
des graines on a le bois d'artnet le
bois de judas et le bois pions la
deuxième partie de notre 2
notre voie c'est donc le recyclage c'est
à dire qu'on a fait des jeux à partir de
recyclage du plastique etc nous avons
aussi fait comment loto quine donc avec
des bouchons que nous avons repris pour
faire jouer les gens pour les faire
sensibiliser à la chose etc
les ateliers qu'on fait c'est surtout
basé sur un cycle on recycle du papier
journal pour faire des paniers
intéressés et des briques de l'ain pour
en faire un petit porte voix basse et de
ne pas jeter les briques de lait ou le
journal à la poubelle et de lutte et de
lui donner en une deuxième vie depuis
plus de 30 ans mascarin jardin botanique
de la réunion accueille les
établissements pour faire de l'éducation
au développement durable
c'est donc tout naturellement que la
collectivité a accepté ce partenariat
avec le rectorat pour accueillir
l'événement on a aujourd'hui des projets
qui sont portées par les par les
collèges et qui représente vraiment une
richesse pour demain pour la
sensibilisation des plus grands des plus
anciens et même des plus jeunes au
développement durable donc il ya
vraiment un intérêt c'est une mission
fondamentale que porte le département
travers mascarin de d'éduquer de
sensibiliser les collégiens au
développement durable ça concerne
vraiment la préservation de notre
biodiversité la préservation du climat
le recyclage des déchets enfin bon et
les thématiques sont vastes et mascara
est vraiment le lieu idéal pour ça 71
établissements de l'île ont reçu ce jour
là à leur label établissements demandent
de développement durable
[Musique]